The Conjuring universe is poised to overtake
The Matrix as the most profitable R-rated
series of all time.
How did the cinematic exploits of real-life
paranormal investigators Ed and Lorraine Warren
get so successful?
Let's get caught up before the return of fan-favorite
haunted doll Annabelle.
After her first appearance in The Conjuring,
the Annabelle doll became a staple of the
Conjuring universe and even got two spin-off
films of her own.
Starting with Annabelle in 2014 and continuing
with the prequel film Annabelle: Creation
in 2017, the spin-off series has been a modest
financial success.
Though the first Annabelle received a relatively
cold reception from critics and audiences,
the film still grossed over $257 million worldwide.
Annabelle: Creation performed much better
than its predecessor, grossing more than $306
million worldwide.
It also was better received by critics and
audiences, which paved the way for yet another
Annabelle sequel: the upcoming Annabelle Comes
Home.
While the previous Annabelle films have featured
scenarios separate from the rest of the Conjuring
universe, Annabelle Comes Home takes us back
to the Warren household.
Married demonologists Ed and Lorraine Warren
keep a collection of artifacts recovered from
their supernatural cases in a locked room
inside of their home.
This safe room is home to numerous haunted
items, including the Annabelle doll.
In the Conjuring films, the Warrens' daughter,
Judy, is explicitly told to stay out of the
safe room.
"You can't go into this room no matter what,
remember?"
"Yes, dad."
However, in Annabelle Comes Home, Judy's babysitter,
Daniela, shows a dangerous curiosity toward
the Warrens' artifact room.
Having recently lost her father, Daniela is
obsessed with the afterlife, and, as a result,
she accidentally unleashes the evil spirits
kept within the Warrens' home.
After the spirits are unleashed, Judy becomes
the primary target for the evil entities.
Edward and Lorraine Warren, played by Patrick
Wilson and Vera Farmiga, are based on two
real-life paranormal investigators.
The Warrens are famous for a multitude of
paranormal cases, including the Amityville
haunting, which spawned its own franchise
of horror films.
The Conjuring is inspired by another of the
Warren's cases that took place at a Rhode
Island farmhouse in the '70s.
The Warrens also founded the Warren Occult
Museum in Connecticut, which is home to a
variety of spooky and supposedly haunted artifacts,
including the real Annabelle doll.
Though the Warrens are well known, the two
are considered controversial among skeptics.
Neurologist Steven Novella, president of the
New England Skeptical Society, told USA Today:
"The Warrens are good at telling ghost stories.
[...] You could do a lot of movies based on
the stories they have spun.
But there's absolutely no reason to believe
there is any legitimacy to them."
Whether or not their work is legitimate, the
cultural impact of Ed and Lorraine Warren,
particularly on horror films, is undeniable.
Ed passed away in 2006, while Lorraine passed
away on April 18th, 2019.
In the Conjuring films, the Warrens' artifact
room is shown to have numerous haunted objects
from the couple's previous cases.
Throughout the series, the Warrens have advised
people in their house not to enter the room
or touch the objects, since the possibility
of freeing any of the spirits contained within
could be dangerous.
Though we've only seen glimpses of all the
artifacts housed in the Warren house, Annabelle
Comes Home places a bigger importance on the
spirits in that room.
Producer Peter Safran told Den of Geek:
"The idea of actually setting a film around
[the artifact room] was something that we
had in our mind for a while.
[We] just thought that the third Annabelle
movie is the opportunity to really raise the
stakes."
Gary Dauberman, the director of Annabelle
Comes Home, is no stranger to the Conjuring
universe.
Previously, Dauberman has served as a writer
for multiple films in the franchise, including
Annabelle, Annabelle Creation, and The Nun.
Dauberman even got to go on location with
the crew as they shot The Nun in Romania - a
level of involvement not always guaranteed
for a screenwriter.
In an interview with Collider, franchise producer
Peter Safran gave a blunt explanation as to
why Dauberman made the transition from writer
to director for Annabelle Comes Home:
"He got to a place, as a writer, where he
wanted people to stop f---ing up his movies."
Outside of his work on the Conjuring franchise,
Dauberman also worked on the 2017 adaptation
of It and is slated as a writer for the upcoming
horror projects Are You Afraid of the Dark?
and It: Chapter 2.
In the Annabelle Comes Home trailer, a new
supernatural entity can be seen standing in
a corner of the Warrens' artifact room.
After Daniela goes against the advice of Judy
and enters the room where all of the possessed
objects are kept, she hears the ghostly voice
of a woman:
"I like your doll."
That wedding dress belongs to the entity known
as the Bride.
Early reports say that the Bride is a new
monster in the series that possesses women
who wear her dress and convinces them to kill
their husbands.
After each woman is made to take out her new
spouse, the Bride goes ahead and kills her,
too.
The introduction of a new demonic presence
could be a sign of films to come, especially
since previous spin-off films have been introduced
in a similar way.
In both of the main Conjuring films, Lorraine
Warren has the ability to see and communicate
with ghosts and demons.
In the first film, this ability is demonstrated
when she's able to see the evil spirit that's
haunting the Perron family.
The Conjuring 2, meanwhile, begins with Lorraine
having a dark vision during a seance and communicating
with the demon terrorizing a family.
Lorraine is also able to see the evil nun
entity throughout the film.
In the trailer for Annabelle Comes Home, Judy
mentions that she can "see things" just like
her mother Lorraine.
This implies that a prominent plot point in
Annabelle Comes Home will revolve around Judy's
apparent ability to communicate with the evil
spirits.
A trend in the Conjuring universe is that
the sets for many of the films are allegedly
cursed.
The unit publicist for Annabelle Comes Home
told PopSugar that ever since The Conjuring
2, all of the sets have been blessed by Catholic
priests prior to filming.
"On The Conjuring 2, we had an exorcist that
was recommended to us by Lorraine [Warren]
- a friend of hers who's sanctioned by the
church to exorcise buildings but not people.
Apparently there are different levels of sanctions
for exorcisms."
With all of the films in the Conjuring universe,
it can get a bit confusing trying to remember
how each story fits into the series' timeline.
Annabelle Comes Home sits at an interesting
intersection in the timelines of both the
Annabelle spin-off series and the main Conjuring
films.
Annabelle: Creation starts off in the year
1943, though the bulk of the film takes place
in 1955, with a group of young girls trying
to survive their encounter with the demon
inside the Annabelle doll.
The original Annabelle takes place in 1967,
as a young couple try to protect their souls
from the evil intent of the doll with the
help of Father Perez.
Annabelle Comes Home will take place in 1971,
but it's not the only film that takes place
during that year.
The new film shares its setting with the original
Conjuring film.
In the opening of The Conjuring, the Warrens
take the possessed doll into their custody
just before they leave for Connecticut.
With the addition of Annabelle Comes Home,
the Conjuring universe has come full circle.
On the screen, Ed Warren is a devoted demonologist
who works in tandem with his wife.
However, Patrick Wilson, the actor who portrays
the late Ed Warren, started out far from the
tense atmospheres and spooky settings of horror
films.
Wilson started his entertainment career by
playing leading men in different Broadway
musicals - and not only did he act, sing,
and dance on-stage, he excelled.
In 2001, Wilson was nominated for the Tony
Award for the best actor in a musical, finding
himself listed alongside acting heavyweights
such as Kevin Chamberlin, Matthew Broderick,
and Nathan Lane.
The following year, Wilson was the only member
of the previous year's nomination list to
return, though he ultimately lost to John
Lithgow.
Aside from starring in musicals and playing
a demonologist on-screen, Wilson has a rather
diverse film portfolio.
He appeared in the 2009 Zack Snyder film Watchmen
where he plays Nite Owl, a former superhero
reluctantly convinced to put his costume back
on after a spree of mysterious deaths.
After getting to play a hero in Watchmen,
Wilson returned to the world of comic book
adaptations to play King Orm in the 2018 blockbuster
Aquaman.
Vera Farmiga has had a successful career on
the stage, in film, and behind the camera.
But the story of how she got here is certainly
unique, to say the least.
Farmiga grew up in a small Ukrainian community
in Passaic, New Jersey.
She discovered her love of performance after
auditioning for a high school stage production
and landing the principal role.
From there, she became part of a semi-professional
Ukrainian dance group.
After high school, Farmiga went to Syracuse
University to study acting, ultimately embarking
on a professional stage career, where she
was noticed by television and film producers.
This attention led to roles in The Departed,
Down to the Bone, and The Manchurian Candidate.
After appearing on-screen alongside the likes
of Meryl Streep, Heath Ledger, and Robert
De Niro, she was nominated for an Oscar in
2010, for her supporting role in Up in the
Air.
Annabelle is a terrifying antagonist onscreen
— and the ostensibly true story behind the
real-life Annabelle doll is just as horrifying.
Supposedly, the Annabelle doll was bought
by a woman for her daughter, Donna.
Unfortunately, after Donna was given the doll,
she and her roommate started to notice some
strange occurrences around the house.
A medium claimed that the doll hosted the
spirit of a young girl named Annabelle Higgins,
who was found dead where their apartment was
built.
According to the medium, Annabelle wanted
to remain close to the girls.
Feeling compassionate, the roommates gave
Annabelle's spirit permission to stay with
them in their apartment.
However, after recurring bad dreams and suspicious
noises in the apartment, the Warrens stepped
in.
"We are beyond terrified.
We don’t know what’s going on, or what
to do.
Can you help us?"
"Yes we can."
They told the girls that the Annabelle doll
was inhabited by a demonic entity, and the
doll was exorcised and given to the Warrens
for safekeeping.
After Annabelle allegedly attempted to have
a priest killed, the Warrens moved it to their
Occult Museum.
There, it remains a popular attraction for
tourists and supernatural enthusiasts.
While pretty much every film in the Conjuring
universe has deep themes relating to Christianity,
the Annabelle films take a bit of a different
tack.
They usually feature concepts regarding the
nature of motherhood, and the sacrifices that
parents have to make to protect their families.
In Annabelle, Mia's willingness to sacrifice
herself shows how the best mothers are willing
to give everything to keep evil from corrupting
their children.
Annabelle: Creation shows just how desperate
grief can make people.
In their desperation to get their daughter
back, the Mullin family welcomes what appears
to be the spirit of their dead daughter into
their house.
However, the spirit is actually a demon that
goes on to terrorize the Mullins and the orphans
they'd taken in as a form of personal penance.
With Annabelle Comes Home, audiences may see
some of these previously explored themes revisited.
In The Conjuring, Lorraine is extremely concerned
with the well-being of her daughter Judy,
even seeing visions of her dead body floating
in a river.
With Judy now targeted by Annabelle, it will
be up to Lorraine to protect her daughter
from the doll's evil influence.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Conjuring
universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.